Hi. In this video, we're going to look at analyzing session token generation using BurpSuite.
Session tokens must be generated in a way that makes them unpredictable. If a session
token is predictable, it can expose a website to session hijacking attacks where an attacker
accesses another user's active session. If this is an authenticated session, the attacker
could access the user's data and potentially perform malicious operations on behalf of the
user. You can use BurpSequencer to collect a large number of session tokens and analyze
them for predictability. You can follow along with this process using our deliberately vulnerable
demo site, ginandjuice.shop. Before you start, log into the target site to generate an authenticated
session cookie. On our demo site, you can use the credentials Carlos and Hunter 2.
Go to the proxy, HTTP history tab, and look for the response that issued your authenticated
session cookie. Select the session cookie. Right-click and choose Send to Sequencer.
Check the token location within response is set to the session cookie you want to analyze.
In the Sequencer tab, click Start Live Capture. When the live capture is complete, click on
Analyze Now to analyze the tokens.
You can now review your results. The Summary tab gives you an overall assessment of the randomness
of the tokens. The other tabs can be used to perform a deeper analysis.
The Summary tab is a little bit more than the same. The Summary tab is a little bit more than the
! The Summary tab is a little bit more than the same. The Summary tab is a little bit more than the
Summary tab. The Summary tab is a little bit more than the same. The Summary tab is a little bit more than the